problema número 248 y ya estamos en la
recta final de estos problemas
el triángulo rectángulo de qr se grafica
en el plano xy de manera que el ángulo
recto esté en el segmento pr es paralelo
al eje x las coordenadas x y xi de pq y
r
deben cumplir con que x sea mayor o
igual a menos 4 y menor o igual a 5 y
debe ser mayor o igual a 6 y menor o
igual a 17 cuántos tengo los diferentes
que cumplen estas restricciones se
pueden graficar dibujemos aquí primero
las restricciones pensemos en donde
podemos colocar estos puntos cual valor
puede tomar x bueno las restricciones
son con respecto a x que va de menos 4 -
1 - 2 - 3 - 4 de aquí a x igual a 5 1 2
3 4 5 son menor o igual que como es
igual toma en cuenta estos puntos
entonces nuestros valores en x van a
estar en este rango de menos 4 a 5
ahora con respecto a y el límite es de 6
y 16 veamos bueno esto no va a estar a
escala digamos que nuestros 6 está aquí
y nuestro 16 va a estar
16 así que la restricción en james va a
estar desde aquí hasta acá muy bien
entonces qué valor puede tomar x
contando este punto 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
puntos x pueda tomar 10 puntos así que
de nuestro punto p dónde está el ángulo
recto este puede tomar 10 puntos en x y
en cuántos hay bueno de 16 menos 6
incluyendo los límites 16 66 10 más 111
porque estoy incluyendo los límites
tengo aquí 11 posiciones en p puede
estar en 10 en x en 11 lugares en y para
p hay 110 posibilidades de lugares para
colocar ahora vamos a dibujar no sé me
imagino que p va a estar por acá ahora
una vez que ya tengo establecido qué
opciones hay para él pues la coordenada
hdr debe ser la misma que la bp pues pr
es paralelo al eje x pero no puede tener
mismo valor o posición que p así que r
tiene nueve posiciones que puede ocupar
r puede ocupar nueve ya una vez elegida
la p vamos a dibujar ere a la misma
altura que p este es mi segmento pr ya
que tenemos pr fijas que coordenadas
quedan para q pq tienen que formar un
ángulo recto así que la coordenada x de
q debe ser la misma que la de p pero no
puede ocupar el mismo punto cuántas
opciones de lugares hay para y bueno en
cu quedamos que es la misma coordenada
xp y lleva a variar pero no puede ocupar
el mismo espacio que p por lo que de las
opciones que tenemos en ya que son 11 le
restamos una y para q nos quedan 10
opciones que se pueden tener
ok entonces ya tenemos todas las
posiciones posibles de estos puntos una
vez que tenemos elegido p luego tenemos
seleccionado ere y finalmente con las
posibilidades de donde colocar estos
puntos son 110 que es el pp por 9 que es
el de r por q que tiene 10 y esto es
igual a 110 por 90 es igual a 99 y 20 es
que tenemos acá 0 0 9 mil 900
posibilidades o 9 mil 900 posibles
triángulos que se pueden dibujar y esta
es nuestra opción se siguiente y último
problema problema número 249 si eres un
entero positivo menor a 200 y 14 por n
entre 60 es uno entero entonces cuando
los factores primos tiene n se entiende
que factores primos diferentes
tenemos que n es menor a 200 y esto es
una entera lo podemos simplificar nos va
a quedar 7 por n entre 30 bueno 7 no es
factor de 30 30 no lo podemos dividir
entre 7 así que n tiene que ser
divisible entre 30 hay varias opciones
que nos pueden servir así que probemos
una de las más pequeñas porque no usamos
en e igual a 30 si suponemos que en es
igual a 30 cuántos factores primos hay
en 30 vamos a hacer la factorización la
factorización prima tenemos aquí 30 es
divisible entre 2 y entre 15 2 por 15 30
15 a su vez es divisible entre 3 y entre
53 por 5 15 y hasta aquí tenemos todos
los factores que encontramos son 12 tres
factores que es nuestra opción b
pregunto si esto será igual para otro
factor de 30 imaginemos que n es 60
cuantos factores primos hay en 60
hagamos lo mismo tenemos 60 si lo
dividimos entre 2 nos va a dar 30 aquí
30 nos da 2 15 y 15 nos da 3 con 5 y nos
damos cuenta que siguen siendo los tres
factores estos dos se repiten es el
mismo así que sigue teniendo tres
factores y con eso terminamos esta serie
de problemas que espero que les sean
útiles para sus exámenes y nos vemos en
otra serie